um so there's two
two things i want to talk about um
they're really
sort of engineering at square
so i'm at core an engineer i like to
write code and sort of solve product
problems through code
but because square touches
dollars quite a lot of dollars so
it's about 20 billion annualized so this
means that you know last month
multiplied by 12 you get 20 billion
a mistake is quite expensive and we need
to be very very sensitive about sort of
and everything we do making sure we
don't leak and sort of cause security
problems but in particular i want to
talk about one aspect of security which
is privacy and making sure that we are
conscious of our seller's data and our
conscience of the card members to sort
of swipe their cards and trust us to
make sure that we don't double charge
them and we don't leak their data and we
don't have
one of the very many security incidents
you're sort of always shocked to hear
that banks have you know lost many many
credit cards somehow
and i also wanted to talk about how
even though in every product we build
the security is very very important we
are trying to be a startup which means
growing very very quickly so we are four
years old actually just turned five we
have 250 engineers already which is far
more than you can
sort of put through a classic training
pipeline and making sure they are each
conscious of all the security
implications so you have to be quite
careful about designing process and some
core tools
to make sure that each engineer is sort
of capable of writing secure code but
not slowed down and actually executing
and shipping fast and sort of
functioning at a
startup so
data privacy is
one aspect of security so i think there
were some people who raised the hands of
security guys we're not going to be
talking too much about firewalls and
like sort of that level of security
partially because i kind of uh
been told not to and then because it's
not uh i don't think it affects
engineers so much if you think of a
typical small startup the security
models very much protect the outside
have strong firewalls and then
everything on the inside is sort of wild
and woolly
but with square
and payment companies in general i think
now more and more because of all the
privacy news people are starting to be
wondering about how to make sure that
data does not leak and the trust
customers data
sorry
place more care and how you use
customers data
so
there's a spectrum
of data that matters right so if you
take imagine square sort of in payment
processing social security numbers and
bank account numbers are incredibly
important to protect
people's names are important from like a
pure privacy aspect but then things like
the size of each transaction is a bit
less important it's basically there's a
gradient
and we're very like we're mainly going
to focus on like sort of the super
secure um the
sort of most sensitive
and
what that requires is in design the
correctness has to come from an end to
end story about how the data is never
leaked
but because the design is continually
fluctuating and things change over time
we need to have
layers that sort of protect us from
introducing code and new code that leaks
service sorry the leaks
secrets
so a core tenant of square sort of
concept around securities does have a
success sorry a secret service should
actually call something else because
it's impossible to pronounce
the idea is it's basically a key value
store
where we insert data like classically
we'll put in a bank account so you put
in sort of security numbers sort of
squares keystick kingdom go inside of
here
and the api is very very simple so you
insert a secret and you get back this
random token that in no way can be
associated with what it maps to
and you use this everywhere
and there's a lot of thought and care
putting into making sure this thing is
actually secure so there's stuff about
hardware security modules there's stuff
where you can basically take the data
off the machine like you just copy the
database stuff and remove it from the
hardware and try and boost another
machine it is not actually accessible
because the encryption sort of happens
in hardware
but all of this is sort of available to
engineers within square as a pure key
value service
so anytime you have to access i mean so
imagine trying to take a credit card
transaction the key piece of data is
what is the credit card number
and you don't have to worry about gee
how do i make sure that i don't leak
this you simply insert it into the
secret service and you use this token
everywhere when you're referring to it
and through sort of one api like this
engineers are protected from having to
know
more or less anything about security
right if you trust sort of the
abstraction then you can write secure
code by default and there's no
sort of additional complexity there and
it lets you move very very quickly
engineers understand key value stores
they're very simple right this
particular one is backed by you know my
sql database but that's totally
irrelevant right it's very simple api to
understand and to use
and the other part
of making sure we don't leak data is
around credit card numbers and you don't
have much control over
sort of the distributed service that is
square
so we have our data centers right which
you know they're physically protected we
chose the data center provider that's
quite expensive but sort of very very
focused on making sure people have
physical access
but the reality is that our clients are
running on people's phones right which
potentially have been side loaded might
be viruses there and how do we make sure
that they're not stealing encryption
data sort of sorry credit card data
while you know merrily swiping credit
cards
so what we've actually designed is in
this piece of hardware
this is our latest uh sort of reader we
launched about a month ago
and it's actually quite incredible so
it's the size of the iphone right
um it's quite cheap to manufacture in
the sense that we basically give them
away
and there's no battery but even so
as soon as you swipe a credit card
through it there's actually a hardware
bit on it that goes and encrypts the
credit card number so if you were not
running the square app you try to run a
microphone or whatever it comes out as
pure pure noise
it's unfortunately couldn't get a demo
to work but it's it's very excruciating
it's just pure noise
um and each reader has a separate
encryption key so in the factory they're
basically burnt in unique to each reader
uh you know the by the pup sort of the
the key
but what's interesting about that is
then we can go and feed it into our risk
system so because the each reader is
uniquely identified and how it encrypts
the the credit card code we can actually
create a story around how many readers
are being flipped into a phone whether
the reader is being reused between
multiple phones and then use this as an
extra signal when trying to decide how
how much risk and fraud there
potentially is with the transaction and
if you imagine square as a business sort
of our top line revenue comes through
building better products driving more
revenue
and having people use this in more and
more and more stores but at the end of
the day our profit sort of the bottom
line comes from being very very
sensitive to how we manage risk and not
exposing ourselves to to more
basically to fraudulent readers so if
you imagine
you know to give you one little example
of ways
square could be abused
if a credit card gets stolen you know
the first question that comes to mind is
has this credit card been you know is it
basically available and can you swipe
and take payments on it in the old days
you'd have to go and go to a coffee shop
right and try and charge and if it
didn't work there's embarrassing there's
like a security risk that maybe you'd be
you know sort of caught so to speak or
you have to pay cash
now with sort of any of the mobile like
providers not just square right you can
sort of pull your phone out and try and
charge it for a dollar just to see if it
works
um
and these things sort of in the
financial model of credit cards are
quite expensive because not only are we
out
whatever the um sorry not only are we
out the extra dollar but there's this
sort of extra fee sort of what's called
a chargeback that become quite expensive
and there's too many of them and sort of
our ability to process credit cards get
shut down by banks because they felt
were too risky so this sort of all comes
together in that from that one little
piece of hardware
um
it's quite incredible yeah
but sort of in practice so we have our
secret service you know developers are
using it
we hope right so what happens when you
know
they write they ship code
they introduce a bug how do i limit our
exposure
so what we have developed is basically a
system of layers that are combination of
process and technology right that i
think on on their own each one's quite
simple but together it creates quite a
good blend of being
catching bugs
limiting the
amount of exposure we get from them but
also keeping developers agile
and
i think that's very hard to do
especially keeping so
having process that helps developers and
makes them sort of move faster
as opposed to slowing them down is quite
a trick
and i think we've done a good job of it
but let's let me give you like five sort
of hand-picked examples of how i do this
so one is within square our entire
architecture has been very much
influenced by google because our cto was
sort of at google for many years we
heard many googlers they've basically
tried to rebuild google
and so we have a service container
that and it's
built through particle buffers you can
very easily map down that this is sort
of the message that your service sends
this is sort of the endpoints it has and
very quickly build out basic services
and they have instrumentation around
this is the amount of resources they
need it's memory intensive so let's keep
it on memory intensive hosts there's
stuff around automatically routing
requests based on whether
a service endpoint is healthy or not
there's stuff around making sure that um
requests stay within data centers
and
but failing over if the data center is
down
and around this sort of or in this world
we have these annotations so one of them
is redacted it's like this so when you
create for example a payment message
this is like a very sort of minimal one
imagine that you have this name so
debugging is something every developer
wants to do it's sort of a core tension
of engineering is that you want as much
data as possible to help debug the
problem but then from a privacy
standpoint we don't want to give you
much data at all in fact we're going to
give you ideally zero so how do you
resolve the two
so through things like you know this
redacted option basically we can
continue to log every request and show
this in various sort of profiling and
debugging tools but know what fields are
considered especially sensitive and
almost not relevant to
what uh what you need to see so redacted
will mean that it's sort of x out we
have another field that will basically
you know hide it by encrypting so it's
sorry the hashing so you can tell if
it's the same value right but you won't
actually be able to know sort of what
lies underneath
and so what happens is that when a
developer accidentally turns on the spew
and they start you know they save a log
to their personal laptop
the amount of data that's sort of
available there is very very small
however you can leave the annotation off
right so another thing we do is that we
automatically scrub logs for suspicious
looking pieces of data so this is pretty
easy to do for particular kinds of
numbers so any number of that form
really really looks like a social
security number and we just remove it
through pure regex there's a bit of
complexity around removing things like
names we don't do a hugely great job of
it
but it's an extra layer to sort of help
limit the amount of data exposure that
happens during a bug
and then we want to prevent bugs in the
first place so we have as part of our
development methodology we're very very
large on pairing we think it's an
effective way to help developers on
board and sort of learn relatively
sophisticated systems
and we actually enforce this at the um
i mean in our case we use github but we
enforce it at the source control level
so you cannot merge into a master branch
without having at least one other
developer sign off in your commit this
is classically done by letting another
developer do your merge
and so a corollary that is we are very
very insane about testing
um
we have tests for basically everything
they are excruciatingly slow to run if
you were to try and run them just on
your laptop they would take
that sort of last count just about 36
hours
but we've gone and built sort of a
custom tool that will parallelize the
testing across a couple hundred
aws hosts making it much more palatable
so it takes about five to ten minutes
and every single commit
that gets sort of pushed to central
repos is tested
then must go green before it's emergent
to master
and this is
uh
i'll tie it together in a second so with
the pairing and production is sort of
more of an operational feature and i
think it's something actually most
companies do but it's worth emphasizing
which is that anytime you are in a
production system right you must be with
someone else this is not something you
can kind of really enforce from a
technological standpoint they could try
and do like a double key thing
but it's just sort of a good sense of
having someone else see koji run and
make sure that you're not either one
deleting data or doing something quite
foolish
or basically being exposed to more data
than you need to be so you might imagine
to find track down the bug in production
you want to figure out you have to look
at some real life data but one of the
things we always ask ourselves is you
know what is the data we care about and
can we basically if we're pulling out a
database row what are the columns we
care about and we
are very very paranoid about not using
more than that so we would like not use
the name if all we needed was a
timestamp
so pulled all together the real goal of
this is sort of twofold right so it's
very important to not make mistakes and
not sort of lose data in general these
mistakes kind of have
you know not much of a cost the most
important part is to not be consistently
making mistakes because that's how you
get
basically holes and through that we feel
you know this notion of end-to-end
correctness is where it comes from so
things like the secret service and
making sure it's always used means that
we have a single place within our data
centers that we have to enforce and
protect although it's actually multiple
places
and we have a notion sort of extended to
access control as well so there's a few
different services that each own a
particular pile of data and it is their
responsibility to make sure that each
request that they receive is
authenticated we have sort of the
inverse almost of
the security at the outside and
everything within is trusted
the security for us is at core right as
close to the data as it possibly can be
and that's where things are validated
and while we have additional layers
around that those layers are
protection against sort of bugs
and to offer sort of a better developer
or customer experience in some cases
but the thing i try and keep in mind is
that if you do the process correctly you
can actually get it out of the
developer's way to where someone who
joins square
can do a production commit in like two
or three days
and not worry that it breaks production
this is actually if you fully embrace it
it's greatly empowering because it means
that you as a developer can go and touch
any system within square and be quite
confident that you are not going to
cause a security problem and you are not
you know ideally going to introduce sort
of correction correct
behavioral bugs either but security is
sort of
thing we care most about
so the other sort of thing i wanted to
talk about
was actually also finance driven but
from a different angle which is
how availability and sort of the classic
concepts of availability are slightly
different when you're dealing with money
so classically an available system is
one that you know you're expected to
give your correct response within some
very finite amount of time
with
payment processing it's a little bit
different so the correct response for a
seller like they don't really care about
what's the rpc what went over the
network all they want to trust is that
they swipe a credit card and they'll
receive the money for it
so
they don't care where the money comes
from right they just want the money
and it's sort of our job almost to make
sure that we get the money from the
credit card holder
but there's various ways we can sort of
make up for
systems that are down and unavailable by
effectively using our own money floating
it
exposing ourselves to risk but carefully
managed it's a way sort of using the
financial underpinnings we have of
buying uptime
relatively cheaply actually
so this is
you know
was not approved by our design group but
basically it's a very rough sketch
of
what
networks are touched when you swipe your
credit card in an ideal world so one
there's this magnetic sort of feel that
gets manipulated when you swipe at the
right speed there's the within the rear
it basically takes the digital reading
off the magnet thing encodes it so it
encrypts it encodes it as an analog
signal sends it into the phone the phone
then decrypts sort of converts the
analog signal to a digital value using
very like 90s modems technology
does the computation it needs to and
then it will send it either over wi-fi
or 4g or 3g or
like if not with maybe 2g
in the worst case the sort of square
servers and then square we'll go and
talk to the bank make sure you have the
funds in an ideal world and then it will
send a response back to the cell phone
saying that you know you have been
charged
there's quite a few places this can go
wrong right so
one place is between square and the bank
so there's actually quite a few banks um
there's
these are many billions of dollars and
not just technology you can't just fail
over from one bank to another there's
all this sort of
contractual obligations that we have to
fulfill
so if a bank isn't responding the
obvious thing to do
is you can create basically a backlog
right so you can either fail the request
which is sort of shitty or you can you
know use a classic journal
stick entries in there and then when the
bank becomes available flash it the
problem is what do you tell the merchant
in the meantime
and one thing we can choose to do
is basically take on the risk that the
credit card is either invalid or going
to be declined
and
basically eat it so we can offer a
better experience for merchants
realistically the banks don't go down
that often sometimes it just takes
longer and we might choose to do this
not so much because they're unavailable
but because we want to hit a different
latency requirement and they can
realistically offer us so we might want
to do offer a response within half a
second but the best you know the bank's
way to commit to is two or three seconds
the other part is around sort of this
part of the network right where either
the magnetic card is sort of not swiping
or the reader is
broken it happens
um and you know we work very very hard
to make the reader as strong as we can
but ultimately it's in the merchant's
power to make up for this they can
either ask for another credit card or
they can ask for cash or most of them
have been sort of trained to keep an
extra reader alongside just in case
there's problems
but the part is really interesting is
actually this right so what happens if
the cellular network is unavailable or
the wi-fi network is unavailable and
this happens quite often it's one of the
biggest complaints we get from merchants
and the thing you can do here is very
similar to what we do with the banks
where we will logger you will log the
request
assume it to be approved and then when
available
flush them through to square and
ultimately get the money back but the
problem
is if you look at square's growth
when we first sort of launched four or
five years ago
the
key feature we had was that for suddenly
all these people who could not accept
payments or be signed onto a typical
credit card process because of all the
fees and sort of the process required
there are on square and there are you
know mom and pop shops they're farmers
marketee type
stands they're small operators and
they're not
hugely sophisticated like ideally they
don't want to be thinking about any of
us at all
and if we do the logs approach we're
either exposing square to a significant
amount of financial risk because you can
imagine there's quite a few ways of
abusing this
you take a bad credit card and keep
swiping it for a hundred dollars right
um or you have to basically educate the
merchant that there is a decline risk
and you have to give them controls so
for sophisticated merchants for larger
ones this is a totally standard thing if
you look at any of the larger coffee
shops or even the larger fast food
restaurants they they will all
basically you know accept credit cards
even if the internet's completely down
and then in the future they will they
will flash the logs
because they've run the numbers and they
think you know they sort of understand
what's going on but how do you explain
this to a merchant who doesn't
fully understand basically how the
credit card works
um and partially part of the idea is
that you can offer better controls so
you can say up to 25
the other part of this goes into who at
the merchant store is uh sort of enabled
to make decisions about the merchant's
financial exposure right it should not
really be the cashier
it probably wants to be the owner so how
do you sort of offer this feature to
them and like basically what is the
product design that goes into educating
our merchants to drive sort of a better
a better product and finally with any
new products right security guys um get
involved and their minds is only a brand
new attack vector right if you were to
side load some little
what's called virus on your phone right
it could try and manipulate sort of the
in-memory information
about what's you know how much was
charged who was charged and things like
that
and you can also imagine that if you
were to lose the device or with the
brake
you're basically out the money as well
because you know you cannot flush your
logs
so those are like
i think it's you know two different
parts of square that i think most people
will find a bit surprising right so one
is the uh
you know the financial parts and sort of
how
in many ways you might be slowed down
because of the fact we're dealing with
money
but sort of put together and correctly
managed i think we can make engineers
move faster
but then also through
how we're dealing with money lets us
build sort of interesting products so
one other like little anecdote that i
always find sort of super cute is if you
think about database lag
it's usually an arbitrary number right
it's like you know two to five seconds
but for us we can actually quantify how
many dollars are represented by that two
to five seconds so if we were to lose a
database and lose two to five seconds of
basically transactions and knowing who
to charge we can attach a number to it
and very rationally decide is this worth
um is this worth improving and
shockingly enough it
you know rarely is
so it's sort of fun to be able to throw
money at some of these problems and
basically buy better availability
but yeah
so
any questions about like
other things go for it
oh sorry so the question is basically um
in europe in particular does this drive
for chip and pin right so instead of
instead of swiping a credit card and
signing you stick your credit card in
the machine it has this little
electronic chip and you enter a pin
number after this is validated uh it's
sort of generally believed to be far
more secure than than swiping because of
this sort of two-factor aspect of it
um you know this is
we like to get bigger as a company right
so these are things you're going to
think about quite carefully i'd imagine
the heart would be quite different but
otherwise we haven't you know announced
any plans for the chip and pin chip and
pin world
oh it's it's completely um sorry so the
question was how exactly does it work
that you plug this little device into
the microphone port
and you know it sends data to the uh it
sends data to your app
the app effectively starts recording
um
so one thing that you know if you think
about the power requirements of
encryption and making sure that the card
swipe is read and all of that
you might think that we actually also
turn on the speaker part to effectively
drive you know a very sort of passive
source of power into the rear but we
have sort of
advanced and sophistication enough to
where we can build our own chips so this
is not necessary but at core the reader
creates a sound so
it's not really easy to do anymore but
you could used to be able to plug it
into your microphone and then like swipe
a card and hear this like terrible sort
of noise basically
the square app knows how to understand
that noise basically so if i select
this card
yeah so i mean we're trying to magnetic
so there's like all kinds of standards
that go into
the data that's on the cards is
basically there's usually two tracks one
of them has your name and like a
particular set of fields another another
the other track has like a few other
fields and you also can negotiate better
rates depending on which track you use
but sort of at core yes we can identify
what kind of card it is
and you can try and swipe like your
metro card or something those actually
don't work with our reader but from a
few other cities they do and but it's
just bogus i mean has no meaning as a
credit card
so in the same way you can type random
digits into a website
there's two two sources of power um
there's one is from the basically the
background noise so to speak so by the
way i'm not like a hardware guy but from
you know in my understanding this is
background noise um that's sort of is
one source of power and then yes there's
actually quite a bit just comes from the
active swiping
number sorry so the question
was how do we
manage risk sort of a square in
particular around sort of catching
fraudulent charges
um going back to the 200 employees
number we have a very significant amount
we sort of are focused on
combating fraud how much we can talk
there is relatively limited
because you don't want to sort of give
too much information and
just bad things happen
so we can talk a little bit offline
sorry going back to how it could work
question um i mean so it knows when you
swipe the card right it basically sucks
down a bunch of random bytes so there
are little readers you can buy they'll
show you what's on the card it's totally
in the plain text like it's going to be
your name
possibly slightly cut off and then all
the like all the numbers that are on the
card um and there's like an extra piece
of data that lets you know that the
number was retrieved from the swipe as
opposed to just read off
but
you know the data is either there or it
isn't there and you know it might be
corrupted but it's hard to tell like to
some extent you know we have to try and
be sort of sophisticated about detecting
bad cards as early as we can because it
offers a better customer experience
but at the end of the day you can't tell
whether or not it's a real credit card
until you charge it
so
sure so uh i mean the question is you
know on one hand you don't want credit
developers have access to credit card
information on the other hand you know
how do the developers develop
um
so i mean clearly in staging you can
feed like i mean so in what sense do you
think there's a challenge
like you know
the production system sure gets numbers
that are valid and meaningful credit
card numbers and then like in testing we
have a certain suite of credit cards
that you know are the numbers are
designed for testing right and then we
can also make sure that the
um requests never leave the system but
like in a completely full and marketing
staging environment you could totally
look at everything that's going on
because all of the data is fake
like it's not actually that
the fact you cannot see the credit card
numbers is not really that onerous
because you sort of build the system
then you trust that it works
sure so we have i mean this is sort of
the role the secret service um
where you want to compartmentalize where
these things are kept so this is
actually very sensitive like what are
the decryption keys and they're kept
alongside bank accounts instead of
social security numbers or let me
rephrase with the same level of care
and
there's a lot of them sure we basically
have one for every reader we've
manufactured right which is you know a
superset of all the readers we've ever
given out
and there's you know a service that sort
of specialty is basically translating
the request
as we receive it from our phone
decrypting everything attaching a bit of
extra metadata that needs to and then
sending that to the bank because the
bank does not understand any of our
gibberish right
uh yeah so sort of glossed over the uh
what's inside of squarepart
we have
i mean it's a large large corp right so
we use some of everything we do use
mysql quite extensively we used to use
postgres sort of full speed
we are unhappy with some aspects of its
scaling in particular that you know it
scales quite well but at some point it
sort of hits a cliff and it goes to zero
which is not like a behavior you want
like you rather want like a slower sort
of failure mode basically things slow
down as you know linearly with the
amount of extra load
um but we still do some amount of
progress postgres uh we're starting to
use react quite heavily we do use hbase
and sort of big table type stores quite
a bit we use a lot of redis
we actually don't use any memcache as
far as i know
and then
in terms of like technologies we use a
lot of java a lot of ruby a lot of
actually now we're starting to use node
um we use some postgres sorry not
postgres right but we also use like
protocol buffers
sort of do communications and we've
built a lot of things in-house as well
sort of over time like one of the things
is the service container that means you
can ship sort of a service that talks to
another service very very quickly
so the question is how do we do
analytics um so we're very very paranoid
about analytics
that's sort of going with most things we
used to use a lot of graphite um it
doesn't scale
uh so we're starting to use open tsdb
which doesn't scale in a slightly
different way um
but it's like generally better um so
there's
so i assumed you meant operational
analytics right because it's different
interesting okay so we uh
let me tell you about operational data
and i'll think about what i can tell you
about the other stuff so and then so you
know the other half of this is so it's
nice to um to basically get
the graphite and open these db will act
as sources of you know seeing as things
are trending over time but in terms of
alerting use you know the classic nagios
with a few you know custom written sort
of extensions
in terms of weather analytics we use
sort of
uh business analytics almost to extend
right we have the classic like bit of
tableau
we're reaching the point that's sort of
i think most companies do
where we're going to build their own
and in terms of the features that
support them you can imagine there's
some amount of online making sure sort
of validating that payments you know are
not obviously wrong there's some amount
of like you know offline trying to train
systems that are better and better at
catching things
um
one of the things we kind of think about
quite a bit is sort of how to leverage
our data to build better products like
you know risk is one of the big things
so as i mentioned earlier like managing
our risk is a huge part of sort of and
really for any credit card processor
it's a huge part of our profitability
um which is another reason you know
can't talk about it too much
so i mean it's hard to speculate too
much about what
the other pan processors things in terms
of our
um its attention so like obviously we
could do with a lot of if you look at
fast food restaurants um
they actually they don't even bother
like doing any validation they just
immediately will accept because they
want the line to liquidate itself as
quick as possible that's the biggest
concern
for us we could obviously do the same
thing it might even be a feature at some
point in the future we exposed two
merchants to basically make the same
choice um but in terms of for us it's a
balance between building a better you
know sort of a better experience that
sort of works faster and not losing much
money
um
there's like the bigger lag issues
really have to do with things like you
know 4g being quite slow and like
seeing the connection
um and sending it sorry from the phone
like to the uh to our data center this
is usually much like in fact it's almost
always the problem and not and not from
square to the banks that's just sort of
easier to like model understand
but
please that you can do it is profiling
your customers given that you get a
different
uh token
credit card there's no way to really
link usage patterns for a specific
account or specific customers so how do
so i mean it's you're not the token is
not generated at the reader level right
so the thing that's important is the
reader has to be able to we have to be
able to decrypt what's there right so
there's additional information sort of
beyond um beyond like the credit card
that gets that gets added right sort of
so there's basic stuff about you know
information about the device itself
right so like you know what version it
is and you know basic statistical things
like that uh and then there's you know
this as this piece of data is wrapped in
the package the phone sends right so it
will send information like you know what
did you buy
so i can send you a receipt through
email
um
so we do have quite a bit i mean so we
do have all the data and the tokens get
generated sort of at the internal serve
service because whenever you need to be
able to refer to a credit card you don't
want to use the credit card number you
want to be able to use this sort of
sufficiently unique
token and that's where it's like all of
our internal
like databases don't have credit card
numbers if there's a very one special
place that does
associated with the device
yeah so i mean uh hmm how much let's see
so there's there's
speaking of guys at usb sticks there's
funny so there's this notion of hardware
security modules that have these bizarre
requirements so one is that they get
burnt in with the code
at the factory and you have to deliver
so if you choose the code you have to
deliver to them using like three
separate sort of certified couriers
going on three separate days and it's
all slightly ridiculous but very james
bondi uh in terms of the factory thing i
mean that might be one way to do it sort
of it's that's like it's unclear why you
need a human to be involved right um
yes i think if you sort of think about
it uh
sort of removing the humans from the
equation then there's there's ways you
can you know make it work
so i i
pretty intentionally gave no details
about how the um
what kind of encryption is this um
so yes we do however have a we've made a
blog post around sort of the the work
that went into the device which might
have actually more information than i'm
sort of you know i so i don't have a
handler here today
so there might be more information that
can that sort of answer your question
but
uh
so square at core wants to you know do
commerce um if you roll up to a merchant
and you want to pay with whatever you
want and you know they were willing to
accept it there is no reason we don't
support it
you cannot currently pay with bitcoin on
square
goodness
anything else
not that i know of but broadly you know
i'd refer you to like our external
communications
so
i'm sorry
oh so i think the question is like what
happens if you use the pay with pay with
your name i guess feature
um
sure so basically this
uh it's so the idea the way this works
for this sort of haven't tried it is you
can go to a merchant square merchant
buy a few things and instead of using
your credit card to pay you can pull
your phone out sort of
you through geo-fencing type things it
knows that you're at the merchant and
it'll sort of pop up on their screen and
then you can say that you know hey put
it on my tab i'm george so the
experience is trying to model is one of
a cafe that you're sort of consistently
coming back to and they know you by name
um
how does i mean from like a credit card
processing standpoint it's pretty like
you know they basically pick your pick
your face you know we know what account
it is and then internally within square
right we sort of build the credit cards
you have on file um we do you know
because the card there's no card
involved for us it's something called a
card not present transaction um you know
to build a better product we don't we
charge the same the merchant the same
amount but that's like you know a
product detail so there's no there's no
real additional complexity there in fact
it's almost the easiest um to think
because there's no hardware involved and
it's similar to like you know you have
an account that amazon and they just
charge your credit card
do you have all your infrastructure
uh no we don't we have dedicated data
centers quite a few of them
uh but aws is like an amazing resource
for precisely this kind of thing right
because it's it's
yeah there's quite a few of them now
well so
it's tricky uh i would usually say
square without failure but you know this
is ebay and they own paypal
but you know
we're happy to like you know broadly if
you imagine the world before square it
was quite a horror story anything
involving credit card you know
processing was just a disaster and it's
very nice that now you know there's
quite a lot of competition in space and
we're all working sort of to make it as
easy as possible to buy things
so
all right thank you for listening